so in summary I am on top of things and
I'm out that teach you a valuable lesson
what lesson I will get back to you when
I figure that out come on
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
looks like you're not done here after
all gelatin
I'll take Stacy and deal with the Jimbo
situation that one's on you
call me when you've got him contained
don't get me fired
[Music]
so was the giant muscle baby working
with the killer robot swing who cares
get in there and find my little boy what
did you do wha
[Music]
you're an atrocious liar but that's not
what I'm calling about the busky house
is surrounded we're to send out the baby
swing as a distraction I need you to
scan the big board and find us an escape
route
tick-tock Templeton the situation is at
crisis levels here
Stacy how's the neighborhood okay I have
an idea and I have a crisis winner me
where's my escape route I found more
cookies and juice boxes Templeton
Templeton where are you I've lost
contact block the door we could busted
this two-year stretch and take care no
they can't send me back to daycare oh
thank goodness
exit route Templeton ASAP or since I got
scooter I can just send him back to his
parents Oh what this situation is a
powder keg and that baby is the
blowtorch you sent about now I'm known
in this neighborhood will ever love
babies again I absolutely forbid wait
where are you right now
[Music]
Templeton you've doomed us all
[Music]
scooter
[Music]
[Music]
we are back to work Templeton hello you
beautiful baby car bosses brother
are they always this friendly I can't
have my own brother ignorant to the art
of business it's embarrassing I make
sure the world loves babies more than
puppies more than kittens what's the
threat what cats don't play by rules
fade up the company's in your mashed
potato hands don't blow it just kidding
of course you will what's up this
meeting is making me uncomfortable
what do we do I'm gonna bag the tiger
[Music]
this is my job on the line you made a
choice to join a family we can fix this
what if you broke something leave it on
the gas just spoon star for Stacey in
fairness sir the cat thought of it first
you can't kill what you can't see time
to go mommy is a dirty liar
[Music]
you